نرجع الى اخبار المنصات والتكنولوجيا وخبر
الان عن شركه متى اليكمان تصدرت الاخبار
والعناوين من بعد تداول وانتشار معلومات
انه الشركه راح تبدا تخفيض كبير في اعداد
موظفيها لكن ما تم ذكر العدد ولا النسبه
وبحسب معلومات
في عمليه التسريح هذه بتعتبر اول تقليص
واسع النطاق لشركه متان من وقت تاسيسها من
18 سنه وذكر تقرير الصحيفه انه شركه متى
وظفت خلال العامين الماضيين اكثر من
20,000 موظف وانخفض سهم مثال 70% بسبب
ارتفاع معدل الانفاق وهذا الشيء اجبر
الرئيس التنفيذي لها مركز انه يتخذ قرار
التسريح وحسب المعلومات المتداوله في
ماركت اكد على تواجد اشخاص في الشركه ما
لهم داعي وبالتالي راح تنفذ متى خطتها في
تسريحهم وخفض الانفاق ل 10% والتركيز على
الاستثمارات الصغيره ذات الاولويه العاليه